[Musica]
[Applauso]
qual è l'origine della felicità
alcuni ricercatori se lo sono chiesto e
hanno scoperto che la cosa fondamentale
avere delle buone relazioni sociali una
salute fisica ed emotiva e la scuola ha
un ruolo molto importante nel crescere
un adulto soddisfatto voi lo
immaginavate io non pensavo che fosse la
famiglia la cosa più importante è invece
le cose stanno cambiando
voglio raccontarvi la scuola la storia
di mio nipote che si chiama mattia a tre
anni lui cercava su uno smartphone di
suo papà di video del che voleva vedere
e anche i giochini usava la ricerca
vocale perché la sorella si era stufata
di aiutarlo qualche mese fa è andato a
scuola ha iniziato la prima elementare e
ha fatto un viaggio nel tempo perché si
è trovato nell'aula esattamente uguale a
quella dei suoi genitori si è seduto e
la mattinata è trascorsa abbastanza bene
fino a quando l'insegnante ha detto bene
bambini ci vediamo domani
a quel punto ma riesco a mar fermi tutti
perché domani devo tornare qui ai
bambini diciamo che devono mangiare i
broccoli perché gli fanno bene allo
stesso modo gli diciamo che devono stare
seduti ascoltare quello che gli viene
detto perché un giorno gli sarà utile
eppure il dibattito internazionale ci
dice cose diverse
ci parla di apprendimento connesso ci
dice che bisogna partire dalle passioni
che bisogna farli lavorare fra di loro e
basarsi su problemi concreti
il gioco fa un po questo si parte da
problemi complessi che non sappiamo come
risolvere e poi si possono in questo
senso
si può usare l'approccio dei videogiochi
a scuola per esempio cambiando il modo
di fare lezioni organizzando delle
emissioni che possono essere a loro
volta suddivisa in piccole attività di
ricerca oppure più semplicemente
cominciare con un approccio più semplice
usando per esempio dei quiz temporizzati
pergami ficcare la lezione perché è
scientificamente dimostrato che
rispondere in gara con altri produce un
apprendimento migliore perché il gioco
ci dà un incentivo a raggiungere
l'obiettivo
lo sappiamo per esperienza che per
giocare bisogna impegnarsi molto ma è
quello che ci dà soddisfazione la fatica
allo sforzo l'impegno e la
concentrazione per questo non sto
dicendo che la scuola debba diventare un
luna park giocare significa mettere in
atto delle strategie procedere per
errori e tentativi ma non vuol dire che
sbagliare sia un problema si cresce
attraverso gli errori si procede al
proprio ritmo e si vedono i risultati
del proprio miglioramento alessandra è
una bambina di 12 anni anche lei e mia
nipote e fa la seconda media e cinque
anni usava già il computer del papa però
è andata alle elementari queste
competenze non le sono serviti a nulla
perché c'è per cinque anni non hanno mai
visto un computer a scuola
adesso fa la seconda media e in classe
c'è una lim una lavagna interattiva però
i professori non sono molto abituati ad
usarla e poi hanno anche dei problemi
tecnici perché la connessione in rete
non sempre funziona bene quest'anno però
la professoressa gli ha detto che
useranno i videogiochi in classe ma non
quelli che ha sul telefonino il
videogioco dovranno progettassero loro
la maestra è entrata in un programma che
si chiama programma anch'io che aiuta
appunto le classi ad avvicinarsi a
questo tipo di linguaggio programma
anch'io ho iniziato un iniziativa arti
di scola una comunità di insegnanti che
ho contribuito
a crescere un po di anni fa lo slogan e
le scuole per le scuole perché crediamo
nella conoscenza e la condivisione della
conoscenza e lo facciamo appunto
proponendo questi strumenti come il
linguaggio scratch che è stato inventato
alle mighty per favorire la creatività e
anche organizziamo festival nazionale
per videogiochi sviluppati a scuola
macello bozzi è uno di questi professori
di questa comunità
insegna qui a grugliasco all'istituto
mari rana e crede che il video giochi
siano il linguaggio che ci permette di
metterci nei panni dei nostri ragazzi
lui voleva affrontare in classe il
problema dei migranti siriani che
vengono in europa per trovare un futuro
migliore
un argomento un po difficile che poteva
risultare un po magari affrontato
superficialmente così ha pensato di far
progettare i suoi allievi un videogioco
il videogioco si chiama il viaggio ed è
un gioco a squadre in cui ogni squadra
una famiglia in cui deve decidere se
portarsi dietro una foto o un paio di
scarpe
immaginate come appunto questo possa
aver aumentato il coinvolgimento di
ragazzi li abbia aiutati davvero questa
volta loro a mettersi nei panni di
qualcun altro
da sviluppare un pensiero critico è una
maggiore consapevolezza
l'ultima storia che vi voglio raccontare
è quella di lorenzo
questo non è mio nipote frequenta la
quarta superiore e sta facendo un corso
per imparare unity unity è uno dei
linguaggi professionali per sviluppare
videogiochi
lui vorrebbe lavorare in quel settore
quindi quando il suo insegnante gli ha
detto che quest'anno avrebbe partecipato
a una gang gen
nell'arco dell'alternanza scuola lavoro
non si è lasciato scappare l'opportunità
e di james sono delle maratone di
sviluppo di videogiochi in cui
sviluppatori game designer sound
designer artisti ma anche non
professionisti studenti si ritrovano in
un weekend
e sviluppano un prototipo di gioco su un
tema dato lo fanno per passione perché
gli piace e che permettono appunto di
sviluppare alcune abilità come lavorare
insieme con persone che non si conoscono
con una pressione legata al fatto che
devono produrre un risultato in un tempo
breve con delle risorse limitate devono
ridefinire il problema fare
brainstorming ed è uno scorso anche
impegnativo sul piano fisico perché
devono lavorare ininterrottamente per
due giorni e due notti però lo fanno
tutti nello stesso spazio e questo crea
un senso di comunità e di condivisione
per questo penso che un approccio di
questo tipo possa essere utile anche a
scuola perché non sappiamo ancora come
sarà la scuola del 21esimo secolo
forse non ci saranno più i voti forse
non cambieranno le scansioni dei tempi e
degli spazi
forse ci saranno delle materie diverse
ci saranno delle materie meno perché
forse studiamo troppe cose ci saranno
dei corsi più astratti un esempio per
esempio è quello di fare delle sfide
dare dei ragazzi dei progetti che
possono sviluppare in modo autonomo con
un piccolo budget perché magari vogliono
fare delle esperienze il lavoro di
domani non sappiamo come sarà forse sarà
meno ripetitivo sarà meno faticoso però
serviranno abilità diverse servirà
empatia capacità di comunicare con
persone con una cultura diversa dalla
nostra saper collaborare analizzare
problemi che tende le decisioni i
videogiochi forse in questo possono
aiutarci ed è compito degli insegnanti
svelare i ragazzi che attraverso questi
questi sistemi possono sviluppare queste
competenze perché l'importante che la
scuola deve dare motivazione e ottimismo
ai ragazzi perché credono nelle loro
capacità e non abbiano paura di
affrontare un futuro troppo difficile
per loro ma ancora più importante è che
lo facciano per tutti perché
ma come abbiamo visto la scuola è
fondamentale per il benessere degli
adulti ed è per questo che matteo domani
tornerà a scuola grazie
[Applauso]